here now with more ranking member of the
committee Texas Senator Ted Cruz Senator
you might want to explain what that
actually means to people so they
understand well sure the the federal
government every year gives millions of
dollars tens of millions of dollars
across the country hundreds of millions
of dollars to airports all across the
country Chicago aare airport gets tens
of millions of dollars and what is the
Democrat mayor doing there he is housing
illegal aliens in the airport he is
trying to use the federal fund that are
given to run an airport that are given
so people can fly in and out of Chicago
fly all over the world instead he's
using those funds to essentially pay for
housing for his Sanctuary City and and
under the terms of the federal grants
the money is supposed to go to keeping
the the airport available for the public
not to be housing illegal aliens and so
I brought together a group of
Republicans on the Senate Commerce
Committee demanding answers from the
mayor of Chicago in terms of why he is
abusing and misusing federal funds to to
to defend his his his policy of
sanctuary City Y well they're doing the
same thing at B Logan airport so this
weekend you were on one of the Sunday
show I don't remember what show you were
on you gave an interview and in the
interview you said it's being floated
that whatever compromise deal would be
made in the US Senate which is different
than the house bill hr2 is a good bill
HR ex is a bill that would really stop
illegal immigration and all the Senate
really needs to do is adopt what they
already passed in the house it would be
that simple uh but you and you're not
the only one that has said this to me
privately that in fact they were
floating trial balloons well uh yeah but
they might allow just a certain number
of people maybe even up to 5,000 illegal
immigrants a day uh you were chastised
by your fellow uh Republican senator
Langford and I'm like okay he's right
the the language has not been written
nobody has a chance to read it we don't
know what's in their bill all we do know
is it's not hr2 um why would we expect
it to be better if it's going to be a
compromise bill with Schumer and Biden
right look in a perfect world Congress
would pass strong legislation that
forces Biden to secure the border right
now as you pointed out the House of
Representatives the Republicans stood
strong they passed hr2 it is a strong
border security bill I introduced hr2 in
the Senate I'm the lead sponsor in the
Senate of hr2 if we wanted to actually
do something to secure the Border that's
what we would do unfortunately this bill
that's being discussed in the Senate
it's not hr2 because Chuck Schumer and
the Democrats said no no no we don't
want to do that that would actually work
so that's off the table and instead
Republican leadership in the Senate is
pushing a deal that would not secure the
Border it
normalizes 5,000 people a day coming
illegally into this country now to give
you a sense 5 ,000 people a day is over
1.8 million illegal immigrants a year
that's about 6 million people during Joe
Biden's presidency he in fact has
allowed 9.6 million in so I don't
understand Republicans saying our
position is we'll take 2third of the
invasion that Biden's allowed we're okay
with that that doesn't make any sense to
me and so my view this Senate deal is a
bad deal I've made this case repeatedly
to my Republican colleagues the Speaker
of the House has been unequivocal this
bill will not pass it's Dead on Arrival
in the house and I said to my colleagues
all right if it's not going to pass the
house what the hell are we doing why are
we giving Democrats an excuse because
you know what Chuck Schumer's doing you
know what Joe Biden's doing you know
what every Democrat runner for
re-election is doing they're saying well
gosh we would have secured the Border
but the Republicans won't pass our bogus
bill that does nothing to secure the
border that is just dumb it's political
malpractice we ought to fight to really
secure the Border I'll tell you Sean how
we do that we do that by beating Joe
Biden in November by electing Donald
Trump again as president and Donald
Trump I worked hand inhand with Trump we
secured the Border in 2020 and we'll do
it again but Joe Biden has no interest
in doing that by the way and then I I
see that you're up for reelection and I
read is it true George Soros is pouring
all of this money into your state
targeting you and every Republican in
Texas in the hopes of turning Texas blue
is that all true Sean that that that is
exactly right Chuck Schumer has made
clear I am his number one Target in the
country George Soros the news broke last
week is pouring Millions into the state
of Texas trying to beat me the Democrats
are going to spend over $100 million and
my last reelection I won by less than
three points we had a poll come out just
two weeks ago that showed this is a
two-point race and so I I look I want to
tell your viewers if you want to see
Texas standing strong fighting to secure
the boorder fighting against This
Disaster from Washington I want to
encourage people go to Ted cru.org go to
tedcruz.org make a contribution give
2550 $100 we are facing $100 million on
the other side we're facing Chuck
Schumer and Joe Biden and George Soros
and they want to take me out because if
they flip Texas the country's gone and
so I want to encourage folks go to
tedcruz.org and and stand together to
fight to take our country back and six
years ago uh at this time you might
remember uh the world didn't quite know
how nuts that b boo oror they found out
later but uh anyway you've been fighting
hard for the people of Texas for
securing our borders and have been one
of the few reliable conservative voices
uh in the Senate thank you Senator hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else